today's video is brought to you by
Dollar Shave Club are you sick of
choosing between overpriced razors and
low quality plastic disposables well
Dollar Shave Club has your solution
their razors provide a high quality
close shave
for the price of a disposable
dollarshaveclub.com amazing razors right
to my door for a fraction of the price
that I used to pay seriously I have no
reason to deal with the drugstore hassle
and battle the locked up razor fortress
ever again and neither will you when you
join the club
just go to dollarshaveclub.com forward
slash comments explain and get a 1 month
membership of any razor for $1.00 free
shipping no commitments cancel anytime
with Dollar Shave Club you can look
smell and shave like a million bucks
without paying for it and here's your
chance to discover why millions and
millions of members like me love Dollar
Shave Club just go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash colors
explain and get a 1 month membership of
any razor for $1.00 free shipping no
commitments cancel anytime
guys this is Rob coming at you with
another episode of how to kill
superheroes you know the name how to
kill superheroes is sort of interesting
because we don't necessarily always kill
superheroes like sometimes we kill bad
guys but I feel like it's a good general
name how to kill a person with
superpowers doesn't have the same like
pop or pizzazz for anyway
in this video we are going to be killing
the molecule man Owen Reese now before
we get into a discussion about his
powers as always what we end up doing
here is we focus on the history of the
character now the reason why I titled
this how to kill molecule man Owen Reese
or really just how to kill molecule man
slash the Beyonder is because the two of
them go hand in hand and this is
actually kind of funny situation because
for years and years and years there was
just the Beyonder it wasn't until
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers but the whole nature of the
Beyonder was cleared up in a lot of
different ways in relation to the
beyonders which we'll talk about in this
video so Owen Reese originally made his
appearance all the way back in 1963 with
Fantastic Four issue number 20 and of
course he was made by Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby now in this story we're introduced
to a guy who's basically a loser like he
has terrible self-esteem he's pretty
much a pushover by everybody he didn't
really have anything going on now in the
middle of a lab experiment he's
basically kind of just exposed to this
radiation that ends up in dowling him
with just these in crazy powers to
manipulate reality but the difference
here is that he requires a wand and more
often than not when he used these powers
in this early story it was really just
like making small things happen they
need snow in an office or something like
that it was never really anything big
and grandiose of course he became a
villain of the Fantastic Four and he was
handled pretty readily by the team and
more or less just kind of defeated now
fast forward to 1984 with the original
secret war story and in this event is
actually told to us as the reader that
the molecule man Owen Reese is one of
the most powerful beings who have ever
existed in the history of the entirety
of the multiverse the reason being
because of the fact that he can
manipulate molecules and the molecules
that he manipulates are not limited to
any one particular universe meaning he
can cross over into other universes and
manipulate those molecules as well the
reason why he wasn't able to use this
power before as it was explained by
Doctor Doom is because of the fact that
the molecule man's lack of confidence in
himself was basically a mental block
and dr. doom removes this mental block
it allows the molecule man to go forward
as one of the most powerful beings in
existence now this coincided with the
arrival of the Beyonder and the Beyonder
didn't really have a story all we knew
is the Beyonder was just there and had
an insane amount of power although we
didn't really know how it worked
this eventually lasted until 1988 with
the Fantastic Four issue number 319 I
think it was and this was basically a
story that dealt with the secret Wars
number three more or less secret Wars
number three was supposed to be a great
big huge story but it ended up just
being like a one-issue story and the
Fantastic Four and what we ended up
finding out here was that when the
molecule man was originally exposed to
his radiation what it was was the
energies of a Cosmic Cube that when a
molecule man had performed this lab
experiment he basically opened up a
portal to the realm of the beyonders and
in turn absorbed part of that energy
into himself what was originally
supposed to happen is that the molecule
man was supposed to have some kind of a
containment device usually in the form
of a cube and that energy would be
controlled or contained within the cube
the difference here is that because
molecule man absorbs some of this
radiation some of this cosmic energy
more or less the other half of the
energy basically went out into the
universe and eventually became to
beyonder and so ultimately the two of
them were effectively the exact same
thing split into two separate beings
this eventually led to the you know the
idea of the beyonders but even then
their information was very scant and it
was very limited
fast-forward to Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers and what we
ended up finding out is that the
original Beyonder that appeared in the
first secret wars was basically a child
in comparison to the power of the
beyonders that existed in the secret war
story or at least in the lead up to
secret Wars the power of the original
Beyonder was just that of a child I mean
he was still as powerful but he didn't
know how to use those powers molecule
and Owen Reese was basically on par with
the beyonders themselves he was just
that wildly powerful after learning how
to use his abilities now the biggest
issue with this is that it creates one
heck of a caveat because then the
question becomes how do you kill a guy
who can basically control everything in
existence anywhere and at the height of
its power was second only to the one
above all well we try to kill the one
above all before
and that's really about it but let's go
ahead and dive into his powers a little
bit let's talk about the molecule man's
abilities so actually stated the
molecule man can control matter down to
the molecular level and that means that
he can change literally any substance
into anything he wants if he wants to he
can turn the Empire State Building into
jello or you get on the Fantastic Four
into stone there is literally nothing
that you can think of that the molecule
man cannot do which makes him a reality
worker of the highest level in Marvel
Comics now again this is not the first
time that we've tackled reality wars in
this series I mean we've already done a
video on how to kill Franklin Richards
another one of the most powerful beings
in Marvel Comics but in that video we
had a much clearer path to shutting down
the source of Franklin's reality warping
ability which was is being empowered but
Owen Reese is not a mutant
we can't just shut down his mutation and
take away his powers doesn't work that
way and so what we're going to do is
we're gonna have to come up with some
other way to negate the molecule man's
abilities which is definitely going to
be a lot easier said than done
now in order to figure out how to take
out the molecule man I think the first
thing that we need to figure out is
where he fits in in the Marvel hierarchy
with regard to this level of power now
like other characters that have been
around for decades the molecule man's
been written and rewritten at various
power levels throughout his history but
at the height of his powers he was again
second to the one above all he was more
powerful than Welding Tribunal he was
certainly more powerful than Galactus or
any of the other cosmic entities he was
right up there with the original
Beyonder and so to give you guys some
perspective in terms of just how
powerful he is
during Secret Wars to the molecule man
repairs damage that the Beyonder had
caused throughout the entire multiverse
by simply lifting a finger and when he
engaged the Beyonder in battle the
resulting tremors of their fight was
felt all throughout every single
dimension he's withstood a blast from
the Beyonder that's produced enough
energy is said to be powerful enough to
destroy billions of dimensions and who
want to The Watcher even remarked that
Owen Reese would be capable of
destroying the entire multiverse if he
chose to and so the question becomes
again is it possible for us to kill
someone as powerful as the molecule man
well ultimately I think the answer to
this is yes we can kill the molecule man
but doing so will probably be the most
daunting task that we've tackled in the
series other than the one above all
himself so it's not really going to be
an easy thing but
thing we have to remember is the
molecule man despite having insane
reality working powers is not
technically invulnerable what I mean is
that while he could turn a bullet into
death before it hit him if he was hit by
the bullet it would affect him just as
it would affect any other human being
furthermore molecule man has no
superhuman physical attributes like
strength speed or durability those are
all things that he can give to himself
because of his powers but they're not
inherently available to him and so this
means that technically molecule man can
be killed in any conventional way but
this does not solve our problem as we
still have to deal with the fact that he
could turn us into a pile of dirt or
simply vaporize us the moment he senses
an attack so how do we do that well as
it turns out the molecule man does have
a weakness that we can exploit when the
character was originally introduced it
was believed that he was only able to
manipulate inorganic molecules meaning
that he was unable to control anything
organic or anything that was alive now
again as it was later revealed this
limitation was actually a symptom of his
own insecurities he just simply didn't
believe that someone as insignificant as
himself could control reality but of
course as we stated dr. doom basically
removed these mental blocks which
allowed him to control everything and so
with that in mind it seems to me that's
the best and really the only way to get
around molecule man's reality-warping
ability is to try to prey on those
insecurities and to do that we're going
to need a telepath now luckily for us we
have several of these high-level
telepaths at our disposal in the Marvel
Universe we've got Charles Xavier we've
got Emma Frost we've got Jean Grey the
list goes on and on so if we got one of
those telepaths on board which I can't
really think of very many that would be
willing to attack the molecule man but
if we got those telepaths on board then
I think that we should be able to do one
of two things either we can plant enough
self-doubt in molecule man's mind so
that he can no longer exercise full
control over his powers or we can just
shut down his brain and it's how can
more leave in a comatose state now I
think either of those have the potential
to work but the latter of those two
seems to be the most likely to succeed I
mean it's not the most honorable way to
defeat someone I think that leaving the
molecule man conscious is a dangerous
proposition even if we are able to shake
it self-confidence and interfere with
his powers to some degree and maybe you
think that using a telepath as a cheap
way to get a victory but really unless
you're the one above all or the Beyonder
your path to defeating molecule man is
going to be a very narrow one so I don't
think that we can afford to be
soozee in this particular circumstance
but the fact remains uh this is it this
is the only way that I could conceive of
to kill the molecule man Owen Reese the
only other possibility the only other
thing that I could possibly think of to
take him out would be to use jason
wyngarde remember the molecule man can
only really combat a force if he knows
that forces there but one of the reasons
why jason wyngarde or mastermind is so
powerful is because he dominates the
five senses of the human body or any
organic organism and so because of this
he basically manipulates the sense of
taste and touch and smell and hearing
and seeing and so on and so forth and so
if he chose to he could make you believe
that you were a pirate in the 18th
century and you would smell the salt on
the air and you would feel a breeze on
your skin if you would genuinely believe
you're there if we could get mastermind
on board mastermind would basically
allow us to manipulate the five senses
of Owen Reese and in turn convince him
that he's in any particular situation
that we choose and in return we can
practically kill him under virtually any
circumstance that we want to we get to
shoot him inside of the head we could do
any number of things to him but aside
from a telepath a high-level telepath or
jason wyngarde there really isn't a way
for us to be able to get around the
reality warping powers of the molecule
man being years to basically vaporize us
and destroy us in our entirety so
without being said guys order to go
ahead and bring this video to an end if
you are new here to come us explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all right
there face
[Music]